on sait très bien que le plus important
ce n'est pas le physique mais c'est ce
qui a dans la tête fort
par exemple moi je me sens vraiment mal
quand je raconte une personne je sais
pas si c'est une fille ou un garçon
ces gens là ils le savent on a dû leur
dire déjà dit mille fois
alors pourquoi ils font pas un petit
effort en mettant un signe distinctif on
dirait que ça les fait qui fait de jouer
à avec parfaitement ans tous les deux
désolé mais c'est normal que tout le
monde prenne pour un mec t'as vu vendu
ta vie mais je suis je suis vraiment un
mec en fait à west pour ça en fait il
faut assumer son physique parce que les
gens qui ont des complexes
ça se voie directe comme les assume pas
une partie de leur corps ou leurs
physiques tulle gris tout de suite et
c'est encore plus ridicule ses excuses
moi je suis désolé mais qu'est ce que ça
te faire tes compétences et de ton
sourire ou ah non pas du tout c'est
juste que je pue de la gueule
c'est comme les meufs qui veulent pas
qu'on regarde leurs fesses parce qu elle
les trouve trop grosse
elles font tout pour le cacher mais
c'est grillé à dix mille kilomètres
du coup on le voit encore plus quoi
juliette au tableau oui racines de 8
après il ya aussi l' inverse des mecs
qui sont complexes et c'est ce qui en
fait des tonnes
par exemple les mecs qui ont un tatouage
on dirait qu'ils font absolument tout
pour le montrer au maximum ouais ouais
voilà avait clairement clairement
clairement après si tu veux ça ça c'est
la base du bouddhisme 1
c'est sur ce qui m'énerve le plus chez
les mecs qui ont été tous âges c'est
qu'on dirait qu'ils doivent toujours le
justifier par une raisons mystiques une
histoire super complexe
bah ça correspond à un moment de ma vie
où j'étais complètement en bad a du coup
je partis avec des potes en inde en
mobylette pour construire une école de
retrogaming pour les enfants malades
il fallait que je le fasse si tu veux
c'est nécessaire on avait besoin
c'est comme si dieu m'avait demandé de
le faire en fait ça veut dire que dieu
te garde à ok mais en fait moi je parle
couramment le langage hindi et je crois
que ça va pas du tout dire ça ah bon ça
veut dire quoi alors bah ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent du fromage quoi jeter son
tube ma gueule mais les mecs qui par des
tatouages c'est le genre de mec qui
portent des chapeaux
moi j'aimerais bien porter un chapeau
mais c'est pas du tout mon style tu vois
ça ne va pas mais dès qu'il met un
chapeau
les gens qui me trouve moche avec pour
bande vexés ils me disent non c'est pas
ta ta pas une tête à chapeaux toi ça
vous à dire qu'à des mecs qui
naturellement ont une tête à chapeaux
genre ils sont nés comme ça coûtait
alors tous vivre garçons s'avancèrent
minutes où est ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'il a une [ __ ] de tête à
chapeau c'est génial regardez ces
magnifiques et des gens qui disent tête
à lunettes aussi mais c'est tout pour
autre chose ça se dit pas quoi et jamais
un mec qui dit ça me va pas j'ai pas une
tête à pul moi je mange et peut-être une
tête à coussins bonsoir c'est comme les
mecs qui porte
des maillots de foot mais dans la rue ça
ça m'énerve aussi les maillots de foot
c'est fait pour jouer au foot sur un
terrain je sais pas les fans de natation
et se promènent pas dans la rue comme ça
moi par exemple je suis blanc dans ma
famille a pas beaucoup de noirs bon et
même 0 en fait et c'est vrai que je suis
pas toujours à l'aise pour parler des
origines
par exemple quand je rencontre un renoi
ou un métis jamais lui demander d'où il
vient parce que j'ai toujours peur
qu'ils me donnent pour un énorme raciste
et toi tu viens d'où en fait pas la
france est pour toi si si non mais enfin
c'est juste que c'est suite à un
physique un peu par tropicale
c'est des fichiers de merde c'est super
cuisse était ou non c'est du moins mais
tu as une vision du moyen-âge mais ouai
j'avoue mais j'avoue mais ça mais c'est
super à ce que tu veux dire
tout seul je suis congolais
t'inquiète negro
à mon sens bientôt classe comme acquis
christina qui revient mars tous les
mardis
moi le courage d'aller bouffer tous les
nuages mon coeur est de classe